and is a famous actor Mike Rappaport hey
Mike hey Mike by the way I heard you
were in The Bachelor fantasy league and
you're not paying your bill that that's
that's actually not true
um and that that's Samantha is I think
she's the one that's spread in that room
where she's full of [__] but the reason
he's calling Sam did he pay or not
excuse me bro you didn't pay and you
know you didn't [__] pay that is some
[__] why are you lying about not
paying pay up no excuse me bro I [__]
paid you excuse me bro
I tried to venmo you twice and you're
like oh my God you sent it to the wrong
Samantha oh stop it Mike come on man you
know that's [__] you that is some
[__] this is dude
everyone else in the league Michael
Rappaport Mike you make a lot of money
you can't beat a guy stiff enough that's
a fantasy league the league was ran
poorly similar to the way
excuse me but that's not why I'm calling
excuse me Samantha excuse me JD what's
going on here Lord excuse me you didn't
pay you cheap [__] excuse me
excuse me [__] came in dead last in
the league he's the idiot uh no wonder
he's trying to back out of paying this
dude says he's the league he knows how
to do fantasy this and that I was on the
phone with him for 20 minutes walking
his ass through how to [__] by the
way Mike I don't mean to embarrass you
but even the bachelor wants you to pay
listen this is Zach The Bachelor talking
about Michael Rapaport I'm the bachelor
Zack shallcross and on behalf of the
Stern Show Bachelor fantasy league
come on man
and buying cookies for the office is not
your payment